[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم من العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن حيث وضع الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب توقيعه على يوم استثنائي في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده امريكيه وبدل
الحديث عن سيناريوهات ادارته وعن ارث سلفه
اختار لهجه لافته وهو يتحدث عن اعاده مجد
امريكا واعلاء مصالحها وجعل قضاياها
الداخليه هي الاولويه وفي اللحظه التي
اتجهت فيها انظار الامريكيين والعالم الى
مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي كذب ترامب
التوقعات بان اكثر تصريحاته السابقه اثاره
للجدل ستبقى مجر شعارات ووعودا انتخابيه
وان لن تتجاوز زمن الحمله فاعاد الى
الواجهه خطابا متصلبا ينشد الحمائيه
والامجاد واراده موجها لامريكا اخرى
منطويه على
مشاغلها يجب ان نتكلم علنا ونتشاور في
خلافاتنا بامانه لكن نسعى دائما للتضامن
والوحده عندما تتحد امريكا سيصبح من
المستحيل وقفها يجب الا نخاف نحن محميون
وسنظل دائما محميين بفضل جيشنا وبفضل
تطبيق القانون والاهم من ذلك سيظل الرب
يحمينا نحن مواطني امريكا سنتشارك الان في
مجهود وطني عظيم لنبني بلدنا ونجدد وعدها
لابناء شعبنا جميعا سنقرر سويا النهج الذي
ستسير عليه امريكا والعالم لسنوات كثيره
مقبله حفل اليوم له معنى خاص جدا لاننا
اليوم لا ننقل السلطه من اداره الى اخرى
او من حزب الى اخر لكننا نقوم بنقل السلطه
من العاصمه واشنطن لنعيد اليكم الى
الشعب هذا وتعهد دونالد ترامب برفع شعار
امريكا اولا خلال فتره ولايته وقال ان على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تحمي
حدودها من الدول الاخرى التي تقوم بسرقه
ثرواتها على حد
قوله رؤيه جديده ستحكم بلادنا بدءا من هذا
اليوم ستكون امريكا اولا امريكا اولا كل
قرار يتعلق بقطار او سياره اجره او خاص
بالهجره حتى ما يتعلق بالشؤون الخارجيه
سيكون لمنفعه العمل الامريكي والعائلات
الامريكيه يجب ان نحمي ح دنا من متسلل
البلدان الاخرى هم يصنعون منتجاتنا
ويسرقون شركاتنا ويدمرون
وظائفنا هذا وتعهد الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب باستئصال ما سماه الاسلام المتطرف
وتوحيد العالم ضده واكد في خطابه بعد
ادائه اليمين الدستوريه انه سيحافظ على
تحالفات امريكا القديمه ويؤسس تحالفات
جديده ضد
الارهاب
سندعم كل التحالفات ونجعل العالم المتحضر
متحدا ضد الاسلام الارهابي المتطرف والذي
سنقضي عليه بالكامل من على وجه الارض اذا
ارحب الان بضيفي في الاستديو السيد سعيد
عراقات الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وكذلك معنا
ميري كيت الموظفه السابقه في البيت الابيض
في عهد جورج بوش الاب اهلا بكم ابدا معك
سيد سعيد عراقات يعني عندما يقول دونالد
ترامب اليوم الرئيس الامريكي
الخمس امريكا اولا عندما يقول بان امريكا
الاكثر عظمه اكثر امنا اكثر ثراء كيف يمكن
ان يترجموا ذلك عمليا وينعكس على السياسه
خارجيه هو حقيقه يخاطب قاعدته الشعبويه
خطابه الشعبوي التي جاءت به الى البيت
الابيض هو يعزز مفاهيم قوميه شوفينيه في
تقديره خطيره عندما تقول ان هذا البلد
اولا اذا ما عدنا الى التاريخ هذا ما حدث
في المانيا هذا ما حدث في في في ايطاليا
فهو يشعر ان هذه الرساله تصل ولها ايقاعات
جيده مع القاعده التي جلبته الى البيت
الابيض وبالتالي يشكل الى حد ما كونه انه
شعاراتي وكونه انه يعزز هذه المفاهيم
الشعبويه التي جاءت به والتي قد لا تنسجم
مع واقع العالم الذي نعيش اليوم في تقديره
تشكل خطوره وتشكل ابتعادا عن الخطابات
السابقه لاحظي ان الخطابات السابقه خطابات
التنصيب دائما كانت تتحدث عن الفكر القادم
الرؤيه القادمه ما قاله اف دي ار عام 3
اننا ليس لدينا ما نخافه الا الخوف نفسه
ما قاله كندي عام 61 ان ال القياده
والسياسه تمر من من من جيل الى جيل وما
قاله حتى ريغن ان الحكومه هي
المشكله وليست الحل هذا يبتعد عن هذه
المفاهيم ويركز على خطابه الشعبوي لانه
يعتقد ان هذه معادله ناجحه سيده ماريك كيت
يعني قيل لي بانك كنت تشاركين في كتابه
خطابات ربما في عهد الرئيس بوش خطاب كما
اوضح السيد عراقات لا ينسجم مع المواقع لا
يعبر عن فكره ولا رؤيه من المعروف
الخطابات السابقه كانت تبدا بصلوات ربما
وشكر الشعب الامريكي على على الثقه التي
اولاها للرئيس الامريكي كيف يمكن وصف هذا
الخطاب
اليوم اقول ان خطابه اليوم كان فرصه ضائعه
كان هنالك الكثير من الاحتمال
لتضمنه الناس ولكنه لم يفعل ذلك بصفتي
كاتبه نظرت الى اليه هذا الخطاب و
الكثير منه لم يكن على اساس ما
قاله الرؤساء السابقين ولكن كانت من
مقتبسا من خطاباته السابقه وكذلك من خطاب
خلال الحمله يوم
الانتخاب وبالتالي هذا الخطاب كان كانت
لهجته لهجه
انتخابيه بالرغم من ان الناس تمنوا لو كان
رئاسيا ولكنه ضيع الفرصه هذه الل اللغه
الخطابيه وهذه النبره الهجوميه التي بدا
بها ترامب اليوم بالتهجم على مؤسسه الحكم
الرؤساء الامريكيين السابقين يعني والتي
لم تبتعد كما قالت السيده ماري كيت عن
لهجته
الانتخابيه في حملتها الانتخابيه الى اي
مدى يمكن ان ان يعني تغير الصوره النمطيه
المعروفه عن الرئيس الامريكي عن دونالد
ترامب نفسه الان وقد وصل الى سده الحكم في
البيت الابيض عند قبل الانتخابات او اثناء
حمله الانتخابات التمهيديه كانوا يقولون
ان هذا خطاب ترامب سيتغير عندما يصبح مرشح
لحزب وعندما القى نفس الخطاب عندما كان
مرشحا قالوا ان هذا الخطاب سيتغير عندما
يصبح رئيسا منتخبا وعندما اصبح رئيسا
المتخب تمسك بنفس الخطاب والان نراه كرئيس
يتمسك في نفس الخطاب انا اعتقد ان ترامب
كرئيس اولا سيعمل ليس بانسجام حتى مع قاده
حزبه لن يعمل معهم
اي بالقضايا التي تهمهم سيكون هناك توتر
كبير بينه وبين الحزب هذا طبعا سيكون هناك
توتر اكبر مع الحزب الديمقراطي في هذا
البلد لا تستطيعين العمل الا اذا كان هناك
انسجام في الكونغرس هكذا تستطيعين ان
تمرري القوانين هكذا تستطيعين ان تجاوزي
الازمات هو
التقط ما اعتبره معادله ناجحه عندما كان
يقول سنجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى وكان
امريكا حارت فهذا النوع من الخطاب الذي
لقي صدا جيدا مع هذه القاعده التي شعرت
انها خارج الاقتصاد الحديث وانه اجحف
بحقها في في عهد
اي براك اوباما الان هو وكانه لا يزال
يريد ان يحصل على اصواتها لكن تاكدي تماما
ان هؤلاء انفسهم يريدون الابقاء على
الضمان الصحي على سبيل المثال لانهم
يستفيدون منه وبالتالي عليه ان يكون اكثر
حذرا وانا في تقديري في الايام القليله
الماضيه القادمه اسمحي لي في الايام
القليله القادمه سنرى ان الكونجرس بقيادته
الجمهوريه سيحاول التخفيف من هذا الخطاب
مدى نجاحهم لا نعرف ا يعني سنجعل امريكا
عظيمه الى اي مدى يمكن ان ينجح في جعل
امريكا عظيمه ان يعيد المجد لامريكا وهو
يتحدث اليوم عن تقليص الانفاق الخارجي
تقليص ربما توجيهي الى الانفاق الداخلي
تقليص المشاركه ربما في بناء البن التحتيه
في اعاده اعمار في برامج مساعدات ومنح
مقدمه من الولايات المتحده الى الخارج الى
اي مدى يمكن لهذا الخطاب وما جاء فيه ان
يمس كل هذه البرامج سيده
مريكي الكثير سوف يعتمد على علاقتي مع
الكونجرس جزء من
خطابه اريد انا ان احرر هذا الخطاب
والاشياء التي اريد ان امحيها انه في
البدايه قام بمهاجمه المؤسسه في واشنطن
ومعظمهم كان يجلس على المنصه الى
جانبه لم يستخدم عباره كلمه فاسده ولكن
هذا ما عناه وهو بحاجه الى كثير من هؤلاء
الاشخاص لكي يساندونه في اصلاحاته لكي
يعيد المجد الى
امريكا اما فيما يتعلق بلماذا توطى اليه
الناس
وذلك لان اعضاء الكونغرس ومسند قاموا
بمساندته والمشكله هي انه اليوم ما رايناه
من حجم الحج انه كان صغيرا وهذا ارسل
رساله الى بعض المسؤولين المنتخبين لانه
لعل الدعم الذي يحصل عليه لم يكن كبيرا
الى الحد الذي تصوره ومع ذلك حصل على
اصوات كافيه ولكن لديه مشكله في مهاجمه
الاشخاص الجالسين على المنصه والان يجلسون
في حفل الغداء واود لو كنت هناك لارى مدى
عدم ارتياحهم لانه لم يتحدث عنهم صوره
جيده صحيح لكن يعني الى اي مدى يتناقض ذلك
ابقاء امريكا وعظمه امريكا مع عدم الانفاق
الخارجي تقليص الانفاق الخارجي اليس
بالضروره يؤدي الى عزله امريكا في النهايه
اليس يعني الا يتوافق الانفاق مع ايضا
القياده
والرياده لامريكا في في العالم بكل تاكيد
الرؤساء السابقون ايضا تحدثوا بنفس
الطريقه اذا ما عدنا الى الرئيس ريجن كان
دائما يتحدث عن الانفاق وان الحكومه هي
المشكله ولكن عندما حضر الى الرئاسه
الواقع يملي شروطه بشكل مختلف تماما فزاد
الانفاق ورفع
الضرائب وعمل مع ال حلفاء في ح حلف النيتو
وزاد من الانفاق العسكري الذي اطاح
بالامبراطوريه السوفيتيه على سبيل المثال
فاذا هؤلاء دائما ياتون
و متم او يقولون انهم يتمسكون بتعهداتهم
ولكن عندما ياتي الواقع كيف سيستطيع ترامب
على سبيل المثال خفض ميزانيه قدرها 600
مليار دولار في الانفاق الدفاعي او في
انفاق السلاح والى اخره كيف يستطيع ان
يخرج من الامم المتحده على سبيل المثال
الولايات المتحده تدفع 22% من ميزانيه
الامم المتحده هي لن تستطيع ذلك لانها
تقود العالم ولن يكون لها دور اذا ما
تراجعت عن ذلك كيف يستطيع ان ان يلغي
قوانين مثل قانون ال القوانين الخاصه
بالمناخ والى اخره هناك ه هذه الاحاديث قد
تداعب مشاعر القاعده التي انتخبته ولكن
الحكم يختلف تماما انا في تقديري اننا لن
نرى الولايات المتحده تتراجع عن معدل
انفاقها لانه هذا ما يجعلها دولتنا عظيمه
ايه واذا فعلت ذلك سنعود الى ما يسمى
بالعزله اي ايام ما بعد الحرب العالميه
الاولى في تقديري ان الولايات المتحده
الان مخرطه في كل في كل بقاع الارض ولن
تتراجع فيض الحديث عن العز عن العزله سيده
ماريك كيت يعني اصرار ترامب ايضا على
استخدامه لمصطلح التطرف الاسلامي هذه
النبره وهذا المصطلح الذي ابتعدت عنه
وربما اداره سلفه بارك اوباما هذا الاصرار
على استخدام هذه اللغه وهذا المصطلح الا
يخشى ان يعني يجعل بعض حلفاء
امريكا يتخلون عن امريكا او ربما من تراجع
دور امريكا في في
العالم لقد كان هنالك قدر ك كبير من القلق
خطابط لم تكن المشكله ولكن حسابه على
تويتر منذ ان تم
انتخابه حديثه عن تخلي عن ناتو ودعمه
لبركس وكذلك حديثه عن الارهاب الاسلامي كل
ذلك وهو يجلس في برج تراور ويكتب على
تويتر كلما تمكنا من احاطته بفريقه
المتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه وكذلك الوزاراء
كلما كان ذلك افضل وانا اتامل ان خطوه
اعلانته عن السياسه الخارجيه لو تباط ومره
اخرى بامكان الكونغرس مساعدته جدا في وضع
حاد لبعض هذه العبارات
والتصريحات داعميه يحبون هذا الكلام ولكن
باقي الولايات المتحده والمؤسسه في واشنطن
تتامل لو انه يفكر قبل ان يرسل
هذه
الاعلانات لذا
نحن السيد سعيد عرقات هل هل يبدو واننا
نعول كثيرا اليوم على الكونغرس الامريكي
في تضبيط بعض هذه السياسات الان في البيت
الابيض بكل تاكيد في نهايه
المطاف القسم التشريعي في الولايات
المتحده قوي جدا في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده هم يمررون القوانين هم الذين
ينفقون الاموال هم الذين يقولون ان هذا
ممكن وهذا غير ممكن يمكن ان ينجح الكونغرس
في ذلك في هذا الدور في تقديري لديه
الاغلبيه في هذه اللحظه تذكري ان على سبيل
المثال في في في مجلس الشيوخ هناك اغلبيه
من 52 سناتور جمهوري مقابل 48 ديمقراطي و
مع هذه الاغلبيه هناك تحقيق الان سيفتحه
الكونغرس فيما يتعلق بدور روسيا في
الانتخابات الامريكيه هل مازال هناك جدول
لهذا التحقيق تيد بكل تاكيد ولكن في
تقديري هذه قضيه روتينيه سيتم التحقيق
فيها وربما سيتم الاستنتاج ان في نهايه
المطاف روسيا نعم استطاعت
اختراق مركز الحزب الديمقراطي ولكنها لم
تؤثر كثيرا في نتيجه الانتخابات ف لان
هناك غضب في بين اوساط الشعب الامريكي ان
دوله خارجيه تمكنت من التدخل في السياق
السياسي الامريكي لكن لذلك يجب ان يتجاوب
الكونجرس على الاقل مع هذه القضيه ولكننا
سنرى ان على سبيل المثال الغاء قانون
الضمان الاجتماعي ليس الضمان الصحي ليس
بهذه السهوله قرار الغاء الاتفاق النووي
الايراني ليس بهذه السهوله الوعود
الانتخابيه شيء والتنفيذ شيء اخر اشكرك
سيد سعيد عراقات الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وكذلك اشكرك سيده ميري كيت كنت معنا هنا
في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن الان
مشاهدينا الى الملف الثاني في حصاد هذا
اليوم مع عبد الصمد ناصر ويقرا في فرص وقف
اطلاق النار في وادي في ضوء سعي النظام
السوري لحسم الوضع الميداني قبل
مباحثات بشان الازمه
السوريه